the last survivors of post-apocalyptic
Moscow are engaged in a daily battle to
breathe clean air find supplies and not
get killed by mutants we first met up
with them in the pc game metro 2033 and
now we're going to find out more about
them in metro last light the survival
horror shooter that's coming to both pc
and consoles we talked to the developers
at 4a games to find out what they're
showing at this year's e3 expo we were
didn't see metro last light as more than
just a sheet of the story-driven action
adventure and it has first person
shooter combat and stove just have a lot
of survival horror aspects exploration
and even some light RPG elements and we
really want to tell this crafted
single-player experience which we think
is becoming increasingly rare and you
really want to make our own entry into
this kind of game so for us this idea of
crafted means having moment to moment
variety so rather than a level just
being this environment this corridor
that your funnel through and the
gameplay is just relentlessly gunning
down enemies that pop up in front of you
it's using a combination or more
emergent gameplay spaces and then some
tightly scripted moment so that you're
constantly giving the player something
new unexpected memorable and
hopefully extraordinary to experience
they go through the game so there's this
huge supernatural angle to to metro last
light with when people see us as a
coaster publix game most people look to
Western kind of examples of
post-apocalypse you know it's blue
sunshine panics in the desert
everything's explicable scientific and
what we have is this kind of heady
fusion of post-soviet realism mixed with
centuries of European mysticism and
folklore so we have this world where
spirits and demons exist you have this
inexplicable psychic phenomena alongside
a kind of crude handmade weapons and
gritty human drama that we tell and it
creates a very heady mix many of the
weapons that we have you can count the
number of rounds left in the magazine
when you hold up to your up tre we try
and tell as much information as we can
within physical items within the game
world so we can strip back the hard
entirely I mean what's your familiar
with the game is perfectly possible to
play through with no crosshairs no hard
know anything like that which for us to
live is that the most immersive metro
experience
you